welcome back to Las Vegas now the
Bellagio Conservatory has transformed
into a lunar New Year's celebration and
it is so beautiful here's Rocky with a
tour
Lunar New Year means new beginnings and
at the Bellagio it means a new display
here at the conservatory um Leah you're
the project manager for the conservatory
so tell us how this one came together
it's beautiful in here well I you know
Ed leby designs amazing Conservatory
designs and for this one is really
thought out put together by over 80
people working 24 hours a day seven days
or six days actually to
take down the holiday and bring this new
design wow okay and let's talk numbers
because that's always fascinating how
many flowers how many props break it
down for us well um you see over 6 500
plants and flowers throughout
um you can look around you there are 88
coins on our money tree and
um I think it's 56 closing a style
cherry blossoms and one large 32 foot
Medallion in the as their centerpiece
wow and I also heard there's one Book of
Knowledge because the year of the rabbit
actually means wisdom and deep
connection which I love people are
making here all the time walking through
taking photos with their families and
friends so let's talk about the story
and Libby we love talking to him about
how he designed the storyline here yeah
you know as you enter you're greeted by
kashin he's the god of wealth you'll see
him right in our entry or east bed
sitting atop of a bridge here and then
if you look over here in our South bed
you'll see a traditional tea house with
the rabbit hopping across the stones to
visit the Jade Emperor's banquet yes
this one seems so peaceful and tranquil
and I also love that you guys moved the
the garden table over here to this bed
as well we did you can come and enjoy
make reservations online to enjoy dim
sum lunch or a feast of prosperity for
dinner I love it that's one of the
newest features here and it is such a
beautiful experience and now moving on
to the Grand rabbit I would say the star
of the show this year this season
absolutely right in the middle of our
Center bed or our West bed you'll see we
honor the year of the rabbit with this
32 foot tall gold and Botanical
Medallion featuring the rabbit in the
center and guard it by two food dogs to
keep the negative energy out oh we like
that we need that okay and of course
last but certainly not least this
beautiful display this one is so
detailed and colorful yeah I love the
north bed because you'll see in right in
the center of it the sixth Canyon tree
Temple it's known for blessings for
children so you'll find our five
children playing in the gardens
underneath made completely out of
Botanical materials underneath of the
traditional Money Tree wow you guys have
to come down tourists locals alike
please come chest just through March
right yes we're through March and it's
we're here 24 hours a day it's free so
come down and check it out now Leah I
have a question you know it is Lunar New
Year what word or what phrase are you
manifesting for Lunar New Year I think
this uh this year after a couple crazy
years I'm going to focus on peace and
Tranquility so I'm going to hang out in
the north bed and listen to the lovely
waterfalls and stay peaceful all right
and I love that it's a cultural
experience a visual beautiful one but
also a learning experience throughout
the display there's some there's some
little cards explaining it right yeah
it's great to completely immerse
yourself make sure you look at all the
frames and read the story behind each
element all right well Leah thank you
for all that you and your team do every
single season this is a sight to see so